élections européennes les bureaux de
vote en france me fernand garnault
heures le pourcentage attendue et
redoutée par les hommes politiques celui
de la participation à 19 heures il était
de 42,2 % contre 48,9 à 20h heure de
fermeture en 1984 sécurité dans les
trains de banlieue en france les
premières patrouilles de crs ont pris
leurs fonctions pour tenter d'enrayer
l'augmentation des agressions + 20 % en
un an
enquête dans ce journal grand prix du
canada de formule 1 alain prost
abandonne au troisième tour il était
pourtant parti en tête pour l'instant
c'est ayrton senna qui est en tête de la
course
arrivé en direct dans ce journal madame
monsieur bonsoir
sept des 12 pays de la communauté
européenne était appelée aujourd'hui à
élire leurs députés au parlement de
strasbourg cinq pays ayant déjà voté
jeudi dernier
parmi eux la france où les bureaux de
vote ne ferment qu'à 22h on ne connaît
pour l'instant que le pourcentage de
votants à 19 heures
eh bien à 19 heures ils étaient de 40,2
% en 1984 comparaison à 20 heures ils
étaient de 48,9
c'était à l'époque l'heure de fermeture
des bureaux de vote alors que cette
année vous le savez je viens de vous le
dire
les bureaux sont ouverts pendant deux
heures encore jusqu'à 22h pourcentage
d'abstention important donc mais il faut
avouer que pour les français c'est la
dixième fois en un an qu'ils sont
appelés à voter pour autant et sans
vouloir faire la morale à tout prix on
est tenté de dire que la démocratie ne
s'apprécient vraiment que dans deux cas
lorsqu'on l'a perdu ou lorsqu'on l'a
jamais connue et l'on pense
inévitablement à la chine thierry
calmette la flamme de la démocratie ne
s'éteint jamais voilà leur message
la musique ressemble comédie musicale
hippie des années 60 et en chantant les
étudiants et artistes de renom qu'on
inaugure une nouvelle statue de la
démocratie à visage chinois pour
remplacer celle de la place tiananmen a
battu par les chars de l'armée du peuple
dans la nuit du 3 au 4 juin dernier
symbole dérisoire et médiatique diront
certains peut-être mais au même instant
à pékin place tiananmen images
officielles
les soldats jardinier l'armée refait les
plates-bandes pour sauvegarder les
apparences du printemps pour inaugurer
le grand bond en arrière pour enterrer
les statues de la liberté au nom aux
élections européennes en attendant donc
les résultats qui ne seront connus qu'à
partir de 22h heure de fermeture des
bureaux de vote dans toute la france
voici maintenant les explications sur le
dernier pourcentage d'abstention et de
participation avec pascal guimier qui se
trouve au ministère de l'intérieur
pascal les chiffres ont beau être
provisoire il faut sans appel la
tendance qui était perceptible dès la mi
journée dès 13h se voit donc confirmer
ce soir 40,2 % de votants ce 18 juin 89
ce sont huit points de moins presque
neuf points de moins qu'il ya cinq ans
huit points c'est à dire un peu plus de
trois millions d'électeurs 3 millions
français qui ont décidé de bouder les
urnes aujourd'hui trois millions de
français qui vous le rappeliez il faut
le rappeler peuvent encore voter jusqu'à
22h ce soir exceptionnellement les
bureaux de vote ont fermé très tard au
hit parade du civisme on retrouve un peu
toujours les mêmes départements ceux où
on a le moins voté ses traditionnels la
corse du sud et la meurthe et moselle
paris comme d'habitude se retrouvent en
fin de classement queue de peloton
en revanche il ya deux départements qui
peuvent décrocher ce soir la palme du
civisme il s'agit de l'aveyron et du
tarn la plus de la moitié des électeurs
se sont passés par l'isoloir
et puis c'est l'occasion ou jamais de
parler un peu de nos voisins européens
et de parler de la participation
notamment en allemagne fédérale allait
légèrement supérieur à aux scrutins
précédents 84 en italie celle inverse
est un peu moins qu'il ya cinq ans le
portugal ne vend pas de chiffres en
notre possession
mais concernant la grèce le luxembourg
la belgique et les trois autres pays qui
votent aujourd'hui on s'attend à ce que
le taux de participation soit très élevé
la raison est en fait tout simple c'est
klaba dans ces trois pays le vote est
obligatoire
l'élection européenne oblige encore la
tournée maintenant des personnalités se
rendant aux urnes pour faire leur devoir
de citoyen s'est tournée s'élargit aux
principales capitales européennes bruno
roger petit tradition respectée
françois mitterrand a voté à château
chinon le scrutin européen auront moins
mobilisé les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement à défaut d'une mobilisation
massive des électeurs d'europe en italie
en pleine crise ministérielle
si marion andreotti le président du
conseil sortant a voté la participation
est pour le moment inférieure à ce
qu'elle était en 1984 comme au portugal
en allemagne de l'ouest
la participation est un peu plus forte
mais tous les citoyens allemands n'ont
pas suivi helmut kohl sur le chemin des
urnes électeurs du luxembourg et de la
belgique se distingue davantage leurs
homologues européens
mais si les belges se pressent pour
aller voter derrière le premier ministre
mr fence c'est bien parce que le vote
est obligatoire
en fait il n'est guère qu'en grèce nous
le scrutin européen est passionné les
foules
il est vrai que les grecs et listes en
même temps leurs députés monsieur
papandréou le premier ministre est sur
la sellette
à première vue les grecs sont donc bien
les seuls européens à avoir pimenter
leurs élections européennes d'un grand
enjeu national
la tradition donc suivi du vote de
l'électricien la plus inattendue du jour
c'était en italie la cicciolina député
radical au parlement de rome les
responsables de sa formation ne l'ont
pas couché sur leurs listes européennes
elle n'a pas pour autant renoncé à son
devoir de citoyenne seul son vote est
resté secret pour le reste et n'a rien
caché de ses intentions
vous l'avez vu pour vous donner tous les
résultats à partir de 22h ce soir la
rédaction d'antenne de ces déplacés et
s'est mobilisée elle est ce soir dans la
grande salle du ministère des affaires
étrangères à paris le quai d'orsay un
endroit historique pour la communauté
européenne christian mary mono dans ce
salon du quai d'orsay antennes de
renouer avec l'histoire ici même été
signé en 1950 le traité de paris à
l'initiative de robert schuman est du
chancelier konrad adenauer en 1951 été
créée la communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier
la ceca l'europe et n est confirmée par
le traité de rome de 1957 réunissant six
pays la france l'allemagne l'italie la
belgique le luxembourg et les pays bas
en 73 au royaume uni le danemark
l'irlande adhère en 1981 à la grèce en
86 l'espagne le portugal
quelles priorités pour 89 la présidence
française voudra faire faire un nouveau
bond en avant la construction européenne
dans l'essentiel mans deux domaines
d'abord la construction de l'union
économique et monétaire qui comporte la
perspective d'une installation d'un
système bancaire central d'une banque
centrale dit long d'une monnaie unique
et d'une coordination des politiques
économiques et financières ce que tu un
vaste chantier est aussi alors le
dossier social faire une europe sociale
comme l'a souhaité le président la
république depuis fort longtemps par
l'adoption par exemple d'une charte
sociale qui comportera l'examen des
droits fondamentaux des travailleurs
avec ces deux dossiers là nous ferons
faire à l'europe un bon sérieux en avant
le nouveau parlement européen sera doté
de plus de pouvoir il devra amender les
décisions des gouvernements d
12 et 518 parlementaire fort le marché
unique de 93 l'abstentionnisme ne sera
plus de mise
en direct du quai d'orsay à 22 heures
précise donc la rédaction d'antenne 2
vous donnera une première fourchette non
pas d'estimation mais de résultats avant
de vous entraîner dans un tour complet
de l'europe pour ce faire nous avons
donc installé nos studios au ministère
des affaires étrangères où nous
rejoignons maintenant claude sérillon
claude oui vous voyez daniel se fait
largement plus chic que les studios de
l'avenue montaigne
nous sommes installés dans deux grands
salons galerie de l'apec le salon de
l'horloge avec l'obligeance du ministère
des affaires étrangères il y avait
monsieur dumas qui a son siège à qui je
crois est enfin de travail et d'attendre
avec attention les résultats que nous
donnerons à partir de 22 heures
effectivement sondages mais ensuite
estimations vers 22h30 et 22h45 les
estimations étant beaucoup plus précises
bull bv a comme d'habitude paris match
europe 1 antenne 2 comme d'habitude
encore une fois avec beaucoup de
surprise chez bien qu'apparemment vous
l'avez dit ça pas beaucoup passionné les
français ces élections nous je crois
qu'entre 22h24 heure vous réservent des
surprises d'abord on aura plantu et
iturria plantu vous savez ces dessins
c'est dans le monde dit rien c'est dans
sud ouest
et puis débat avec les habituels
représentants et chef de file des listes
pour ces élections européennes
des directs dans la plupart des grandes
capitales européennes mélina mercouri
sera en direct d'athènes genre récent
prince en direct de madrid
et puis beaucoup de résultats que nous
vous donnerons sur l'ensemble de ce pays
européens europe 1 antenne de
paris-match bulbes et a comme d'habitude
j'espère vous sera au rendez vous après
johnny hallyday merci à tout à l'heure
claude et à toute l'équipe d'antenne de
l'europe politique se construit donc peu
à peu l'élection d'aujourd'hui le trouve
en témoigne l'europe économique sera en
place en 1993 mais pour l'instant sur le
terrain ou plus exactement sur la route
où l'autoroute car c'est l'exemple que
nous avons choisi ce soir les frontières
ne sont pas encore supprimés loin de là
et la paperasserie n'a pas renoncé à son
règne
reportage de rémy roche et jean françois
bernigaud
déjà ça re qu'est la frontière française
derrière une remorque tout juste à
moitié plein et l'impeccable système
autoroutier allemand qui est bien à
soutenir la moyenne deux heures
suffisent pour venir de mannheim où jean
a chargé des machines outils à
destination de barcelone
douanes allemandes puis douanes
françaises pour faire viser les
documents d'exportation de la
marchandise marché commun donc
formalités simplifiées en tout cas ici
tout va très vite
cinq minutes et quelques coups de
tampons une opération vite expédiée
jean ce buzz qui a 42 ans dont presque
la moitié déjà passé au volant d'un
poids lourd
cent cinquante mille kilomètres par an
toujours des voyages internationaux
l'europe
il sait pourquoi il peut en rêver sans
trop y croire une europe concrète 100
postes aux frontières bien sûr mais
surtout avec une réglementation commune
on en est loin dimensions charge du
véhicule durée les temps de conduite
limitations de vitesse tout peut changer
d'un pays à l'autre jusqu'au
comportement de ceux chargés de faire
appliquer leur propre loi
vous allez en italie c'est 80 vous allez
aux allemands ces soixante dix en france
nous aurons bientôt les 190 qui disent
rien mais vous allez en espagne on peut
rouler à 100 est par exemple en italie
si on avait un bébé tout seul peut
toujours discuter sur le prix
samedi 18 à 100000 lire à l'oreille de
bambins en cinquante mille lire tout ça
mais sans facture
kilomètres avalés au troisième jour de
route voici l'espagne donc la fin du
voyage
et pourtant le plus dur reste à faire
jaune franche du port de barcelone
ici jean doit procéder au dédouanement
de la marchandise impossible de savoir
combien de temps cela va durer
d'abord trouver le bon bureau celui du
transitaire l'intermédiaire entre le
client et la douane tu crois pas dit
c'est au deuxième à dire
une fois trouvée y déposer les documents
l'attend commencent elles durent
rarement moins d'une journée souvent
beaucoup plus
ici l'europe ne marche pas ou pas encore
très fort fatigue temps perdu mais
d'abord beaucoup d'argent gaspillé avec
ses centaines de camions immobilisés
on attend que ça se passerait comme on
peut et on attend que ça se passe et
qu'il arrive le vendredi et 10 secondes
lundi pour revenir lundi c'est toujours
la nationalité s'ils jouent enfin
personnellement il ya cinq ans en ariège
78 jours ici il manquait la licence
d'exploitation
sur ces 18 jours
14h30 pour l'éloigner la journée est
finie quelques chanceux obtiennent enfin
leur autorisation de départ les autres
voilà on a répondu à ça la mañana à 10
heures ça veut dire fin demain matin à
10h et j'aurais et papiers à
l'explication pas d'explication tout de
suite sans paperasserie l'arrivée du
grand prix de formule 1 de montréal au
canada lionel avec une arrivée
l'histoire italienne puisque vous le
voyez sur votre image et thierry boutsen
le belge sur la williams de renault qui
est en tête et qui va vraisemblablement
remporté ce grand prix du canada sir et
boutsen donc le belge qui va pour la
première fois de sa carrière au
s'imposer ce sera également la première
victoire du moteur français du moteur
renault tkip seth williams l'écurie
britannique
car il lui a coûté aprilia tour ayrton
senna qui était largement en tête et
dire que cela a cassé son moteur et donc
le belge thierry boutsen s'est emparé du
commandement de cette course et mieux
encore pour la williams renault est bien
en deuxième position on trouve ricardo
patrese sur loucrup diable concerné
train to play de l'écurie britannique
compulser par le moteur français c'est
la première fois donc que renault va
entendre les grands prix avec un moteur
atmosphérique il allait bien sûr
remporter beaucoup de compris avec le
moteur turbo
là ça va être une première et puis aussi
ce qui est intéressant pour les fentes
et et bien c'est la position de rené
arnoux rené arnoux inquiétant
la même position 5 imposition cinquième
position donc pour la vie va marquer
deux points ce qui est très important
pour l'écurie française on avait évoqué
hier dans le journal de 20h qu'est-ce
que ça permettra certainement aux
équipes à l'équipe en tas de ne pas
passer par les pré qualifications alors
que là c'est bien tiré post elle va en
terminer avec le grand prix du canada
grand prix complètement fou perturbé par
la pluie c'était un plus que de la puce
était un véritable déluge de toute cette
fois avec beaucoup de sorties de route
pour tout accrochage beaucoup
d'incidence puisque selon lui
voitures-lits voitures seront à
l'arrivée alors que l'indien le
réalisateur s'attarde sur thierry
boutsen qui a fait le trou avec son
équipier riccardo patrese italien et
boutsen tu vas y si ça c'est les pages
et puis arrivé devant la ligne droite
descend pour remporter le premier grand
prix de sa carrière
c'est mérité pour le belge qui montrait
le très très belle qualité depuis deux
ans notamment la dernière avec l'équipe
benetton il est allé chez williams avec
le moteur renault pour eux pour enfin
remporter un grand prix
eh bien il va y arriver sûr et vous
savez puisque là maintenant c'est bien
les connaisseurs de convent agiter le
drapeau nnomo sa voiture équipée du
moteur français a passé la ligne
d'arrivée vous voyez la pluie qui a
considérablement perturbé ce que l'on
peut retirer pour celles qui passent
devant le train pour rallier qui
remporte donc ce grand prix du canada le
sixième grand prix de la saison pour un
plan tel un prince a abandonné après
trois tours de cours à la preuve c'est
qu'ils étaient victimes d'une
défaillance de sa coque et de sauvetage
des droits a menti a cédé la victoire de
boots même devant riccardo patrese en
bref cesaris et 3e 4e 9 pts 5 et 1
contre bordeaux
superbe performance de rené arnoux est
sixième avec thé café et l'italien si
lionel actualité oblige donc vous avez
vécu en direct l'arrivée de ce grand
prix de formule un du canada je reviens
à l'europe j'en reviens au thème de
l'europe
en effet parmi tous les hommes d'état
qui nous ont permis de construire cette
europe d'aujourd'hui est d'abord de la
libérer pendant la dernière guerre
mondiale le général de gaulle et c'est
une coïncidence de calendrier qui fait
de ce dimanche 18 juin un jour
d'élections européennes est également la
journée du souvenir de l'appel lancé de
londres en 1940 ce soir comme
le veut la tradition le président de la
république s'est rendu au mémorial du
mont valérien vous le voyez en compagnie
du premier ministre michel rocard et du
ministre de la défense monsieur jean
pierre chevènement
monsieur le président de la république a
est rentré dans la crypte du mont
valérien avant de saluer des drapeaux
des anciens combattants et les
représentants de ces anciens combattants
et un certain nombre de personnalités
en bref maintenant le premier ministre
monsieur michel rocard qui reçoit en ce
moment à paris le premier ministre
australien dont le gouvernement et vous
le savez hostiles à nos essais
nucléaires dans le pacifique a déclaré
la france n'entend pas mettre fin à son
programme d'essais même si celui ci a
été réduit un appareil civil des lignes
aériennes d'afghanistan était détourné
ce matin et s'est écrasé dans le sud est
de l'iran une bagarre ayant éclaté entre
les pirates de l'air et les membres de
l'équipage on n'en sait pas plus pour le
moment
tout comme on ne connaît pas exactement
le nombre de victimes autour de 23 23
personnes qui auraient été blessés et
peut-être cinq à six victimes l'auteur
des versets sataniques de salman rushdie
dément avoir donné une interview à un
journal anglais dans laquelle il aurait
répété qu'il ne regrettait rien et
dénoncer l'obscurantisme d'un certain
nombre de hauts dignitaires de la
religion islamique retour en france avec
des problèmes de sécurité dans les
transports publics et notamment les
trains de banlieue pour faire face à
l'augmentation des agressions + 20 % en
un an
vous savez et bien le gouvernement a
décidé de former des brigades spéciales
de policiers mais dans un premier temps
ce sont les crs qui ont d'ores et déjà
pris leurs fonctions reportage de
valérie fournis ou gilles dobler il fait
jour sur lequel a fui des trains de
banlieue les risques d'agression infime
dans quelques heures tout peut changer
les bandes organisées signeront les
lignes
pour les contrer la sncf a dû faire
appel aux crs manifestement la chaudière
général à elle seule ne pouvait pas
remplir ses tâches de sécurité parce que
nous n'avions pas assez le personnel
pour pour accomplir ses missions le fait
que le vieil homme et allant des crs le
soir et de manière régulière dans
l'autre va contribuer à rétablir ce qui
va de sécurité qui est tout à fait
normal
a la sncf un uniforme comme moyen de
dissuasion une présence pour assurer les
voyageurs et les agents sncf
ce samedi soir première patrouille
cela ne faisait pas dix minutes que nous
étions dans un train qu'un homme nous
suivait cherchant la présence et la
protection des crs pour calmer son
angoisse ya des soirs où je me sens pas
sécurité ce tout cas je voudrais vie
mais je voudrais suivre la charge de la
gorge des suivis parce que le fait
d'être avec vous bien au moins je
m'attaquerai y boit tous les jours je
pèse 50 kilos mais toujours présente à
autre par le travail qu'il fait de vous
se prêtent à 6034 dégoût j'étais mené
ces trois fois moins alors vous avez une
situation provisoire
ces sommes seront bientôt remplacées par
une brigade spéciale de la police de
l'air et des frontières
dépendante de la guerre dure en
attendant ils patrouillent par 4gate
cherche la moindre silhouette suspecte
le ronde c'est terminé et si un incident
arrivé en leur absence certains abonnés
au train de l'insécurité ont leurs
techniques de vieil habitué chez les
gens dans le pain et 300 places y avait
quelque chose qui sera au complet
un gros combat d'accord il raté des
coups mais on serait pas seul moi je
vous cache pas on va y arriver mais j'ai
quelques rues dans mon sac wagon on
attribue à m
vient l'heure du dernier train celui à
la triste réputation sur la ligne paris
creil la vingtaine d'agents de la
surveillance générale de la sncf
elles continuent de patrouiller
à cette heure mieux vaut ne pas voyager
seul et tenter de rester éveillé avec
trois quarts d'heure de voyage et 12
arrêts le temps paraît bien long dans ce
train qui se vide de plus en plus
une bombe a explosé aujourd'hui vers
midi à l'hôtel devant l'hôtel des impôts
de bayonne dans les pyrénées atlantiques
pas de victime mais des dégâts matériels
relativement important l'attentât n'a
pas été revendiqué encore mais a noté
qu'il intervient au lendemain d'une
manifestation à bayonne demandant
l'amnistié pour les prisonniers basques
français du mouvement iparretarrak la
compétition automobile maintenant à
l'opposé de la formule 1 convient de
voir dont nous avons parlé il ya un
instant ce week-end sur le circuit du
castellet un marathon très spécial il
s'agissait pour les concurrents de
consommer le moins d'essence possible
reportage de patrice blais et jean
françois georges et économiser le seul
souci des techniciens du castelet leurs
objectifs
le record de l'an dernier 1136 km pour
un litre de carburant tout dans
l'aérodynamisme et le réglage moteur un
seul pilote pas trop lourd de préférence
simplement donner l'impression du test
il ya aucun risque parce que le centre
de gravité est plus bas que d'acter
aucun risque d'accident vitesse minimum
25 km heure d engin propulsé par des
moteurs de tronçonneuses de tondeuse ou
d'aéromodélisme et pas question pour le
pilote de s'endormir au volant
il ya beaucoup de chose à s'occuper gars
il faut arrêter le moteur foule a
démarré faut toujours être dans les bons
tours et puis
il est le virage arrive comme assez vite
parce que c'est quand même pas de
voiture de course et ça tient pas
parfaitement là on attend dans un temps
très limité la course contre la montre
même pour une compétition d'amateurs
certains n'ont pas fait ce matin le
moindre kilomètre pour cause de caprice
mécanique des miracles
300 km au lit il
les meilleurs fronts
300 et 400 truites pas de marque en
compétition ce week-end sur le circuit
pourtant les pros il y aurait peut-être
trouvé quelques inventions utile à
condition de ne pas suivre le mauvais
exemple une antiquité hors concours à la
consommation effrayante près de 13
litres aux 100 km on ne se quittent pas
sans un dernier appel de la magnifique
fête donnée hier soir au pied de la tour
eiffel à paris pour les 120 ans de la
dame de fer regarder
guerre
joie
c
et le tiercé maintenant qui se courait
cet après midi à auteuil voilà voici
plus exactement les chevaux qu'il
fallait jouer pour gagner 5 10 et 8 ce
qui rapporte 3897 francs 50 dans l'ordre
pour 5 francs
et pour ce qui concerne le quarté et
bien où nous ajouter là c'est vous
gagnez 29 1891 140 à signaler que pires
avait donné très précisément le tiercé
et le quarté dans l'ordre dans ses
pronostics d'hier après midi
voilà ce journal est terminée un petit
peu en avance sur notre horaire habituel
en raison de cette soirée électorale
pour que vous ne ratiez pas le
rendez-vous de 22 heures précises avec
toute l'équipe d'antenne 2 mobilisés
pour cette soirée électorale que vous
qui sera diffusée en direct du quai
d'orsay à paris avec non seulement des
22 heures tous les résultats mais très
rapidement le tour de france un débat
avec des personnalités également un tour
d'europe puisqu'il s'agit des élections
européennes tout juste après le journal
en attendant cela eh bien vous avez et
les prévisions météo josé blanc lapierre
et puis ensuite david lansky alias
johnny hallyday quant à moi je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée
demain vous retrouverez ici même hervé
claude quant à moi je vous retrouverai
samedi prochain bonsoir excellente
semaine à samedi prochain
à